morning morning Abby what is a dietitian
usually eat for breakfast well if
usually the first thing I ask myself is
to your savory
I think I'm feeling sweet
breakfast so let's see what we got the
fridge and we'll whip something up if
you had to choose one sweet breakfasty
for the rest of your life would it be
oats cereal or yogurt um
I gotta go cereal I could eat cereal all
day every day so that's what we're gonna
do for breakfast Brody I don't care what
you say because that's what I'm feeling
like but I also feel like usually when I
have cereal all on its own I'm not very
satisfied so we're gonna turn it into a
hunger crushing combo my little cereal
hack is to flavor the milk with some
protein powder this is controversial
because I know some folks don't like to
add the milk before the cereal but it's
kind of vital in this situation because
you got to mix it with the protein
powder to get all the lumps out
I like a combo I can never decide what
cereal I want so I'm gonna use all three
all right let's throw in some berries or
some extra fada a little Spoonful it's
peanut butter basically I know I love a
sugary cereal every once in a while but
it just does not keep me full for very
long so I added the protein powder in
there we got lots of fiber rich carbs in
the cereal and the berries plus some
healthy fats in The Nut Butter it's a
perfect hunger crushing combo and I
promise you you're not gonna need a
snack right after well enough talking
man and let me try it